The first thing we want to do is factor our numerator and denominator. To factor
the numerator, we find factors of negative 8 that sum to positive 2. And since
the coefficient in front of m squared is 1, we can use these two factors in our
binomials. For the denominator, we want to find factors of negative 12 that sum
to negative 1. These factors are negative 4 and positive 3. Now, we can't just
use these factors in our binomials since the m squared has a coefficient of 2.
Instead, we'll need to use factoring by grouping. Using that method, we get a
denominator of 2 m plus 3 times m minus 2. Now that we have our factored form,
we can cancel factors that appear in the numerator and denominator. Since they
equal 1. And this leaves us with our solution. We know we can't simplify the m's
anymore since we have a sum and the numerator and the denominator. We don't have
anymore factors to cancel.